[Music]
hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the witches and wizards
of times past i am of course referring
to ghosts
i'm going to start with an introduction
on what exactly our deceased friends
are and shortly after i'm going to segue
into
how exactly one becomes a ghost
according to pottermore
in the world of harry potter a ghost is
the transparent
three-dimensional imprint of a deceased
witch or wizard which continues to exist
in the mortal world
throughout the harry potter books and
films ghosts are quite prevalent
particularly at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
in fact we see them right at the
beginning of the series when they appear
in the great hall shocking first years
who had never seen a ghost before
for harry a boy that had only just
learned about the wizarding world
seeing ghosts was a real trip there are
lots of ghosts in the wizarding world
but the main ones were introduced to in
the series live at hogwarts
nearly headless nick moaning myrtle the
bloody baron
the grey lady the fat fryer professor
bins
and sir patrick delaney podball all
inhabit the hogwarts castle
each tied to the mortal world for their
own unique reasons
so there are ghosts literally floating
around
but the question is why sure their
deceased witches and wizards
but what makes them so unique why do
they remain in the mortal world
when so many others disappear altogether
after sirius dies
harry becomes increasingly curious with
regards to what exactly
it is that causes souls to remain in the
land of the living
venturing to find nearly headless nick
in search of answers
oh very well he nick said looking
resigned
i can't pretend i haven't been expecting
it expecting what
harry asked you to come and find me said
nick
it happens sometimes when somebody has
suffered
a loss well said harry refusing to be
deflected
you were right i've i've come to find
you nick said nothing
it's said harry who is finding this more
awkward than he had anticipated
it's just you're dead but you're still
here aren't you
nick sighed and continued to gaze out at
the grounds
that's right isn't it harry urged him
you died but
i'm talking to you you can walk around
hogwarts and everything
can't you yes said nearly headless nick
quietly
i can walk and talk yes so you came back
didn't you
said harry urgently people can come back
right as ghosts they don't have to
disappear completely
well he added impatiently when nick
continued to say nothing
nearly headless nick hesitated then said
not everyone can come back
as a ghost what you mean said harry
quickly
only only wizards oh said harry
and he almost laughed with the relief
well that's okay then
the person i'm asking about is a wizard
so he can come back
right nick turned away from the window
and looked mournfully at harry
he won't come back who sirius black
said nick but you did said harry angrily
you came back you're dead and you didn't
disappear wizards can leave an imprint
of themselves upon the earth to walk
paley
where their living selves once trod said
nick miserably
but very few wizards choose that path
why not
said harry anyway it doesn't matter
sirius won't care if it's unusual
he'll come back i know he will i was
afraid of death
said nick i chose to remain behind i
sometimes wonder whether i
wouldn't have well that is neither here
nor there
in fact i am neither here nor there what
nick
explains to harry here is that in order
to remain in the land of living
as a ghost you must either be a witch or
wizard
that's the primary piece of criteria
however he also explains that remaining
as a ghost
isn't all that it appears to be in fact
in the above passage
nick himself questions his decision to
remain in the land of a living
here's the thing about remaining as a
ghost you are just a shell of your
former self
kind of similar to the shades produced
by the resurrection stone
you aren't alive and you aren't dead
which means that you can never truly
move on it's a bit of an empty existence
nick knows that sirius wouldn't become a
ghost because he trusts that sirius
has enough common sense not to choose
that sort of existence
even if it means saying goodbye to his
loved ones for good
per pottermore muggles cannot come back
as ghosts
and the wisest witches and wizards
choose not to it is those with
unfinished business whether in the form
of fear
guilt regrets or overt attachment to the
material world
who refuse to move on to the next
dimension as explained above
those who decide to return to the mortal
world as a ghost usually only do so
because they have
unfinished business presumably this
outstanding business is important enough
to prevent them from moving on to the
next dimension should a ghost choose to
remain in the land of living
however they should expect a very
different existence than what they had
during their mortality the existence of
a ghost is rather shunted
as they are no longer able to derive any
kind of physical pleasure as well as
incapable of learning
new things perhaps worse than any other
aspect however
it has been expressed that ghosts harbor
any sort of resentments they had from
their mortality
for the remainder of their existence
rendering them entirely incapable of
moving past things
doesn't sound like any kind of existence
to me
additionally while they exist and do
have a semblance of a physical form in
the land of living
ghosts are mostly incapable of affecting
objects beyond water
fire and air in which they can create
disturbances
when ghosts seamlessly pass through
solid objects it causes the immediate
vicinity around them to feel very cold
witches and wizards are also far more
likely to pick up on the presence of a
ghost
than a muggle which makes sense since
ghosts are magical people
that have moved on according to
pottermore muggles who insist that they
see ghosts in perfect focus
are either a lying or b wizards showing
off
and in flagrant breach of the
international statute of secrecy
in short being a ghost basically sucks
you're in this weird limbo states where
you've chosen to stay
in the land of living to resolve
unfinished business but you're entirely
unable to get past things
which seems to contradict staying in the
first place it also appears to be an
entirely conscious decision
as both myrtle and nick highlighted that
it was their choice to stay
they were brought back to the world of
living voluntarily nick said it himself
he was afraid of death for context here
are a few of the reasons that ghosts of
hogwarts stayed behind
nearly headless nick was a 15th century
nobleman that fell in love with
lady grieve who was a lady in waiting
however when nick attempted to fix her
crooked teeth with a spell
his spell backfired and grieve grew
tusks instead
nick was subsequently sentenced to death
given the premature nature of his own
demise
i can see why he would want to stick
around or why he would have felt that
his business
was unresolved the bloody baron murdered
helena ravenclaw after she refused his
advances
after killing her he took his own life
the chains that the bloody baron has on
him
were an act of penitence for the actions
that he took with helena
i imagine he chose to remain in the land
of the living so that he could repent
his actions for the rest of eternity
professor bin's hogwarts history of
magic professor
died but never even realized he fell
asleep in front of the fire one night
and showed up to class the next morning
in ghost form as if nothing ever
happened bin's
unresolved business is clearly handing
out assignments to students
the fat fryer who was a jolly man in
life was executed by his fellow
churchmen
for showcasing his magical abilities he
was able to
cure pox and pull rabbits out of their
communion cup
and they didn't take to this a jolly man
i imagine he stuck around
just to help out the students of the
school and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it was a
mistake any wizard could make
it was tired and caught on the hop one
piffling error and then to my terror
i found myself facing the chop
you